[Music]
on this monday night
no longer in it together the atlantic
bubble breaks as two provinces put up
new covid 19 barriers
the situation has changed alberta's
situation increasingly precarious
we must take action and ontario breaks
another record
and gets a warning now is not the time
for pandemonium
black friday shopping scenes our big box
store is getting an
unfair advantage i have not seen an
anti-small business measure
like this plus a new tool to assess your
kovid 19
risk and words to live by
in 2020 oxford dictionary's words of the
year
why they couldn't settle on just one
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is lots to get to on this monday
much of it related to the soaring second
wave of cobit 19.
the news starts in atlantic canada where
the bubble that's protected people for
weeks has
burst newfoundland and labrador and pei
have pulled out
because case numbers are rising we'll
get to that in just a moment but first
the big picture
across canada case numbers are up
everywhere
records were set again today in ontario
nearly sixteen hundred new cases and
nineteen deaths
and in alberta where more than fifteen
hundred new cases were reported and five
new deaths
and in manitoba 543 new cases there and
seven more deaths
based on yesterday's numbers manitoba
still has the highest rate of active
cases per capita
followed by nunavut and then alberta
manitoba's test positivity rate is 14
hospitals are nearly at capacity 96 of
103 icu beds are in use now more than
half of them
are active coveted 19 cases more than
900
elective and non-urgent surgeries in
manitoba have been cancelled
in the last month we have covid patients
admitted
in the pediatrics unit in the obstetrics
units
and in the mental health units and i
share this information
in order to reinforce the reality
that we are all susceptible to this
virus
the virus has spread so widely in
manitoba it's now estimated one in every
100 people has had it
strict public health restrictions are in
place there and the rcmp are
investigating
whether some churches broke those rules
this weekend
and in ontario two of that province's
largest regions toronto and peel
entered a four-week lockdown today the
new restrictions mean all
non-essential businesses have to close
but many big box stores which sell
groceries and have pharmacies can stay
open
smaller businesses say the rules make no
sense
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
toronto's the granite brewery was ready
to make the best of it
spent thousands on heaters for their big
outdoor patio
and then the rug was pulled out a
lockdown until almost christmas
disappointed to say the least i don't
say we're a scapegoat but i think it's
let's just say we're an easy target for
people they're trying to appear like
they're doing something
restaurants aren't alone other small
businesses such as florists and clothing
stores feel they're being targeted
unfairly
since big box stores are open and are
selling more than just essential goods
to shut down small businesses that
serve a handful of customers in an
entire day
while allowing those same products to be
sold at costco and walmart
makes no sense at all ontario's premier
is not asking the big stores to cordon
off
non-essential goods they can sell
whatever they have
after speaking to some of the big box
stores it'd be a logistical nightmare
they have
essential items spread out throughout
their whole their whole store and i know
this is not fair
and that's why we put an additional 300
million dollars in to support small
businesses
the problem for toronto and peel
ontario's two largest communities have
the most covid cases
putting hospital capacity at risk
ontario has confirmed over 4 700 cases
in the last three days
toronto and peel alone account for
almost 2 800
the rest of the province saw just 1900
cases
the pandemic arithmetic toronto and peel
represent about 30 percent of ontario's
population
but have reported almost 60 percent of
the covid cases since friday
so don't expect the province to rethink
its 28-day shutdown for most businesses
unless there's a drastic change in the
in toronto and peel i don't believe
those will be changed i'll tell you one
thing if we just ignore the health and
just say okay
let's open everything up we i sure as
i'm saying here we would be in
terrible terrible shape yet another
spreading event looms large
black friday for some of those same big
stores
a stern message from toronto's mayor
don't open for in-person sales of
non-essential goods
we are in the midst of a pandemic and a
lockdown
now is not the time for pandemonium
black friday shopping scenes
the message from mayors throughout the
region this black friday
shop online eric sorensen global news
toronto ontario has appointed the former
head of the canadian military to lead
what the province calls the largest
vaccine rollout in a generation
retired general rick hillier will chair
ontario's new covid 19 vaccine
distribution
task force he served as the chief of the
defense staff and commander of the
nato-led mission in afghanistan
premier doug ford says the task force
will give advice and recommendations on
vaccine rollout when one is approved the
plan is to get it to the most vulnerable
first including long-term care residents
and front-line health care workers the
envy of the nation atlantic canada
is no longer virus free and the strict
rules that kept outsiders from entering
and
let people inside the bubble travel
freely worked for weeks
now newfoundland and labrador and prince
edward island have decided to shut
themselves off even further
mike armstrong reports
it wasn't something he wanted to do but
after a weekend
watching numbers rise in neighboring
provinces the premier of prince edward
island is pulling out of the atlantic
bubble
the risk to our province from an
infection standpoint has always been
from the outside
as of 1201 am tuesday pei is suspending
all non-essential travel staff will be
increased at points of entry
in order to get in travelers will be
required to have a pre-approved
quarantine plan
otherwise they'll be turned back i've
said before that covet 19 is knocking at
our door
and in recent days that knocking has
become louder and stronger
thank you all for joining us here today
now the same announcement from
newfoundland and labrador
that province ii is pulling out of the
atlantic bubble for at least
14 days implementing this change for a
two-week period
is an effort to avoid a full lockdown
now compared to much of the rest of the
country the number of cases in atlantic
canada
is still small but there's been enough
of an increase in recent days to make
people nervous
there also appears to have been in both
new brunswick and nova scotia
community spread it's not just cases
coming in from outside
pei and newfoundland and labrador say
they're going to take advantage of the
fact they're somewhat
isolated geographically to basically cut
themselves off
we're enjoying this level of freedom and
we're the envy of a lot of other places
around the country
we want to keep it that way for now the
bubble continues in nova scotia and new
brunswick but it's tightening there as
well
both are asking people to travel only if
it's essential
the rule of thumb according to new
brunswick's premier
stay at home mike armstrong global news
alberta's top doctors said today that
province has reached a precarious point
covid 19 is spreading virtually
unchecked
this is like a snowball rolling down a
hill growing bigger
and faster and it will continue unless
we implement
strong measures to stop we must
take action premier jason kenney who has
been self-isolating after being exposed
himself has been largely silent for days
and
ignored pleas to tighten restrictions
that might change
this week kenny is holding a cabinet
meeting this afternoon
as heather urix west reports those on
the front line say even if he finally
acts
now it may be too late
they are powerful images from alberta's
front lines photos from the icu
in this one a doctor calls a family to
tell them a loved one has died of
covid19
this is where we're all suffering our
families don't get closure
our nurses are the surrogates for
morning and the physicians are
carrying these things knowing that the
next
10 15 20 patients are vying for that bed
dr daryn marklin says some of his worst
fears are being realized
his icu at edmonton's royal alexandra
hospital is full
and painful triage decisions are now
having to be made
those tough decisions are actually
happening as we speak
there is a lot less latitude for taking
a long shot
alberta has seen rising case numbers for
weeks now and the actions taken so far
by the province
have had little impact the numbers paint
a picture
cases began increasing soon after
thanksgiving on october 26th the
province put a mandatory limit of 15 on
social gatherings but only in edmonton
and calgary
the curve didn't flatten so on november
13th bars and restaurants were given a
curfew
organized sports ended and fitness
studios closed
but more than a week later this virus
has shown no sign of slowing down
it is probably too late to continue with
with light approaches the higher this
curve gets the the longer we go
the more people in the hospital the more
severe
the actions will have to be in order to
turn the curve around
last week as cases surged across the
country alberta's chief medical health
officer
was left to report numbers alone every
premier of
in the country and the prime minister
spoke directly on this matter and some
like doug ford or john horgan introduced
new measures
and the premier was nowhere to be found
the health minister
was nowhere to be found the alberta
government is expected to announce new
measures tuesday
but during question period monday
alberta's health minister
seemed to rule out any kind of lockdown
we'll continue to impose public health
measures that are based on the evidence
that are narrow they're targeted
they're going to minimize business
disruption back on the front lines dr
marklin has
one question for the premier what's
taking so long
i like to sit down and have a beer with
him just to figure out what
he's really thinking about the big
picture
because this is so far away from reality
that i wonder
i just i can't understand it heather
urex west global news
calgary nunavut is nearing the end of
the first week of a
two-week circuit breaker of restrictions
new cases are still emerging there none
of its first covid19 case was
november 6. there are now 132 active
cases
in the last 24 hours four new infections
were reported plus dozens over the
weekend
today's count includes three new cases
in rankin inlet where 18 people have
tested positive and another person
contracted covid19 in whale cove where
there are now
16 active cases the federal government
has launched its revamped
rent relief program for businesses
charities and non-profit groups
the canada emergency rent subsidy will
be paid directly to commercial tenants
and property owners
unlike the previous rent support program
which relied on landlords to apply
it will cover up to 65 percent of rent
and mortgage interest
with an extra 25 available to those
hardest hit
and the program will run until at least
june of 2021.
the one bright spot is the promise of a
vaccine and it moves closer to reality
every day
today the one being developed at the
university of oxford is showing promise
a trial of more than twenty thousand
volunteers found it highly effective at
stopping symptoms of covid19
interim data suggests it gives 70
percent protection on average and may
increase to as much
as 90 percent by tweaking the dose
redmond shannon explains we wanted a
vaccine for the world
not just for high income countries not
just some of the team behind the oxford
university
astrazeneca vaccine share their good
news with royalty
in the most pandemic way possible on
zoom
it's an amazing achievement isn't it it
really is this latest shot in the arm to
covert 19
is the fourth late stage trial with
encouraging results
russia's sputnik 5 is reported to be 92
percent effective in protecting people
from covet 19.
the pfizer bioentech vaccine is said to
be at least
90 percent effective modernist protects
up to
95 percent of people this latest vaccine
appears to be 62 effective with two full
doses
but as high as 90 percent when the first
shot is a half dose
averaging out at 70 percent that might
sound low but none of the people who got
the vaccine and still got coveted 19
were hospitalized and this vaccine has
two big selling points
it is considerably cheaper than pfizers
or modernist
and it doesn't need to be kept as cold
you don't need a freezer to store the
vaccine you can
distribute it in the conventional way
for all vaccines
keeping them in a two to eight degree
centigrade fridge
that is big news in countries that lack
special freezer facilities
the uk has 4 million doses ready to go
with regulatory approval possibly coming
as early as next month
the bulk of the vaccine rollout program
will be in
january february march and we hope
that sometime after easter
things will be able to start to get back
to normal the oxford vaccine makes up
20 million of canada's 358 million
covert 19 vaccine orders
we have built up a really robust
portfolio of orders and purchases
it's going to be essential to have close
collaboration between the federal
government
and the premiers of the provinces as the
second wave continues across canada and
here in europe
medical experts and politicians warn
against thinking the fight is anywhere
near
over redmond shannon global news london
covet 19 and the climate crisis coming
up the effect of the pandemic
on greenhouse gas emissions
in the u.s the transition from the trump
administration to president-elect joe
biden
will finally begin the administrator of
the general services administration has
formally designated biden as the winner
that
triggers federal funds and resources to
begin the transition
president trump who has spent more than
two weeks claiming falsely he won
tweeted today that he accepts the
decision but will keep fighting the
results
a delegation of nba stars went to the
vatican today invited by pope francis to
talk about social justice
the pope said he was eager to learn more
about their social justice activism and
talk about police brutality
plus racial and economic inequality
during the meeting which lasted about an
hour pope francis commended their
efforts calling the players
champions there's a reality check
tonight on greenhouse gas emissions they
are down a bit in 2020 because of
reduced activity during lockdowns but
it's not enough to make a difference to
the big picture
according to the world meteorological
organization co2 levels the most
abundant greenhouse gas hit record highs
in 2019
and are rising in 2020 that's despite
the pandemic grounding planes docking
ships and keeping commuters home
estimates suggest those things cut
global emissions up to 7.5 percent
but it's just a tiny blip on the
long-term graph and not enough to curb
co2 levels that are
trapping heat in the atmosphere the
organization says the pandemic is not a
solution to climate change that
sustained an ambitious action is
required by all countries to reduce
emissions
to net zero still ahead a new tool helps
gauge the risk of visiting a loved one
in the pandemic
as we've learned to live with the
coronavirus which was brand new to
humans new information has emerged and
public health rules have evolved
it's not always easy to know if you're
doing the right thing perhaps the most
challenging is knowing when it's okay to
visit elderly loved ones
as abigail beeman reports there's a new
tool to help you answer that question
and determine your own risk i'm from
toronto these university of ottawa
students are figuring out their holiday
plans they haven't been doing much of
any visiting for a while
we don't really we just stay in our
apartment mostly the whole entire time
and what made you make that decision um
because there's okay
visits can be really helpful for our
mental health and well-being
it allows us to actually provide care
and support to other people
and so this is why we don't want people
to stop visiting
when when they can visit but figuring
out who and how to visit can be tricky
especially with a deluge of messaging
some of it mixed and confusing people
get infected
when they are in places with other
people i urge
all islanders to keep their social
circles small
we know that covenanting moves as we
move
the national institute on aging has
released what it believes is the first
of its kind a personalized
self-assessment tool to determine risk
it's meant to
actually help give you all the
considerations that'll help you
understand how risky your visit could be
and the things you can do to actually
lower the risk of the visit
the assessment asks three dozen
questions and takes about 10 minutes how
long is the visit
indoors masked how will you travel there
and it asks about your health
and the health of the other people
involved in the visit
it's meant for people of all ages the
experts behind the tool say
local guidelines take precedence this is
a complex landscape when it comes to
information
we don't want people to use this as
license to break the rules
the assessment can also help with sticky
etiquette situations when it feels rude
to turn down an invite
the tool offers an evidence-based way to
say no
not just about giving you know people
the freedom to go out and visit it's
also giving people the
right to sort of say look i don't
actually think it's safe
this is a made-in-canada tool but those
behind it hope it gets pick-up globally
especially for the holidays
and for the u.s it's been launched in
time for american thanksgiving
with much concern over travel this week
abigail beeman global news ottawa
next oxford dictionary's words of the
year because one
just isn't enough
i bet a lot of you have some choice
words to describe 2020
and they wouldn't appear in most
dictionaries but the oxford english
dictionary always does the proper thing
and
keeps up with the times by choosing a
word of the year
well this year it shows a whole bunch of
words the dictionary's president says
it's both unprecedented and a little
ironic in a year that left us speechless
2020 has been filled with new words
unlike any other
mike cherlay on the words we've come to
live by
remember the year the selfie or when
jesus became the way of communicating
without communicating well you don't
have to because
the oxford dictionary made them the word
for their respective years
weren't those the good old days i know
it was it was much easier back in the
day to
you know there's one word and it was fun
and like everyone was like oh great
cool selfie yeah haha everyone take
selfies so
what to do with 2020 and oh my
there were options bushfire for the
australian blazes was an early contender
but then donald trump's impeachment and
acquittal dominated the news
and then it was march and all we talked
about was coveted 19 locked down in
social distancing
before black lives matter and canceled
culture became the
story which was before we circled back
to the pandemic with super spreader
so what oxford do they chose all of them
and yeah all are perfectly fine
but so too is zoom which is how we
captured some of the more uh
indiscreet moments of the year but what
about like
zoom flubs zoom fails zoom fails
yeah zoom fails is is a total thing
sadly it wasn't considered nor was
pandemic puppy
coveted haircut or the awesome tiger
king star carol baskin
seen here as a jiff are any big enough
to knock lockdown off the list
honestly no nor is the child
but watching him float around with
actual astronauts in the space station
for a minute at least i wasn't thinking
about any of those words of the year
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna freeze and we leave you
tonight with this canadian scene ice
beginning to form on
lake winnipeg near arness manitoba
please send us your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
i'll see you back here tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye